[Applause]
colombians are clamoring for change
[Applause]
and gustavo petro is counting on it to
make history
the former rebel came out on top in the
first round of presidential elections
bringing him one step closer to becoming
colombia's first leftist leader in what
is traditionally a conservative country
i trust colombian society in its will to
change
in the end
there are only two options
it's a relatively simple choice
as they are in colombia
which in my opinion is more corruption
more violence
more hunger
or
we can change colombia
petrol is a former member of the m19
guerrilla movement
and a former mayor of bogota
in his presidential campaign he has
vowed profound economic and social
change
a petro presidency would be historic in
more ways than one
his running mate francia marquez is
hoping to become colombia's first ever
black female vice president
for us as a black community it is a
great recognition to see a black person
there black people have always been
enslaved we have always been at the
bottom
and to have the opportunity to be there
and represent us as black people fills
us with pride
petro's coalition fell short of the 50
percent needed for an outright victory
he will now face populist millionaire
rudolfo hernandez in a second round of
voting the man dubbed colombia's donald
trump emerged as a surprise second place
candidate
no matter who wins the runoff on june 19
change is coming
one way or the other
in colombia leftist gustavo petro has
come out on top in the first round of
presidential elections
the former guerrilla and one-time bogota
mayor
has campaigned on a platform of tackling
poverty and crime petro will now face
the independent candidate rodolfo
hernandez in a runoff the businessman
finished in a surprise second place in
the vote
let's get more now from dw correspondent
ramirez he joins me now from the capitol
bogota johan first of all tell me more
about this surprise results
yeah it's very surprising in one hand is
surprising but on the other hand it's a
clear message the colombians are tired
of the political elite here during the
last weeks we have been talking about
gustavo petro the front runner and then
fico gutierrez the right-wing candidate
who is who was supposed to be
in the second place but now the
surprises rodolfo hernandez is getting
that second place going into the second
round of this election and uh is a
message people are tired of the
political elite royal fernandez is an
independent candidate a private
entrepreneur during all his life he was
just once mayor of a little city here in
bogota otherwise he has been all his
life working by himself in a way many
people here in colombia compares compare
rodol fernandez with donald trump
because he has a more unconventional way
to do politics and
now he's at the second runner it's going
to be very interesting to see what is
going to happen the next uh june 19th
when the second round is going to take
place
you say that voters there are fed up
with political elites and and status quo
so what are some of those major issues
that colombia is facing that have
influenced this election and this
apparent outcome
this first round was marketed by
a lot of attacks between the candidates
the two main candidates it was a very
polarized um electoral campaign and i
think that people also was tired of
seeing these candidates insulting
themselves otherwise on the other hand
rodol fernandez was trying to propose
more things and less insulting the other
candidates and i think we can see that
today uh in this result it was a very
polarized
campaign in a country that has been
polarized for more than
50 years after the the during the civil
war so i think people wanted something
new different a more moderate candidate
we are not saying that royal fernand is
going to be the next president but it's
a strong message today in colombia and
is uh
so
this is shaking the political scenario
in the country now
gw correspondent johan ramirez joining
us there from bogota thanks very much